from a terrifying Romanian Abbey to a
murderous occultist in Connecticut the
story told Through The Conjuring movie
spans decades here's how all the pieces
fit together
chronologically speaking The Conjuring
Universe all starts with the nun
released in 2018 this film takes place
in 1952 at the Abbey of Saint Carta in
Romania father Burke and a novitiate
Sister Irene have been dispatched by the
Vatican to investigate the suicide of
one of the Abbey's nuns after a bit of
research they discovered the nuns had
been spending most of their time praying
in shifts to keep a non-shaped evil
entity from hitchhiking its way out into
the real world on a human host as it
turns out the Abbey was originally built
by a Duke during the Middle Ages who was
more interested in Demon worship than
Catholicism he managed to raise the
demon valik but was stopped by a group
of Christian Knights who were able to
seal valik at least temporarily with the
help of a nice local man named Frenchy
father Burke and Sister Irene finally
banished valak back to hell thanks to an
ancient artifact filled with the blood
of Jesus Christ
you should have kept really good you
have the chance
I'm French Canadian
or at least they think they've beaten
the demon but as it happens valak
manages to Hitch a supernatural ride out
of town on Frenchy's back
the Valic character in The Conjuring
universe may have taken its inspiration
from a demon with a slightly different
name described in Aleister Crowley's the
Lesser key of Solomon is a child with
angels Wings riding on a two-headed
dragon The Conjuring Universe version of
valak is clearly not a child and it
doesn't have angel's wings whether or
not it rides a two-headed dragon is up
for some debate since who's to say that
the dragon didn't get left behind when
Valic crossed over from hell one very
specific thing that's mentioned in both
mythologies however is their connection
to snakes like Crowley's demon who is
known to tell where serpents may be seen
the Valic of the 1950s Romanian
Monastery has its own tie to the
biblical reptile along with a much more
impressive title
the defiler
the profane
the Marquee of snakes
as fans of the franchise know valik goes
on to become a major recurring villain
in the story of The Conjuring universe
the nun 2 picks up only a few years
later in 1956 as Sister Irene hides out
in Italy following her battle with valik
but after catching wind of a mysterious
series of deaths not to mention an eerie
vision of a distressed Frenchie the nun
gets permission to investigate these
bizarre happenings sadly father Burke
has passed away but joining Irene this
time around his sister Deborah a nun who
lacks faith of course this all leads to
valik's triumphant return
what did you see
I saw none
during sister Irene's investigation she
learns that Valic is after a Catholic
Relic the eyes of Saint Lucie a
Christian murder who was supernaturally
kept from burning alive equality her
descendants share the eyes of Saint
Lucie happened to be hidden in the
French boarding school where Frenchy
currently works with the help of a young
girl named Sophie Irene uncovers The
Relic which the valik possessed Frenchie
takes for himself soon after at full
strength valik attempts but fails to
burn Irene alive revealing that Irene is
a descendant of Saint Lucy herself after
sisters Irene and Deborah pray fervently
valak is seemingly banished back to hell
and all seems well except it's not the
movie ends with a flash forward to Ed
and Lorraine Warren receiving an
interesting call likely teasing
Frenchy's inevitable repossession or
maybe something even more Sinister the
story of Annabelle the demon doll starts
in 1943 with Annabelle creation when a
doll maker named Samuel Mullins and his
wife Esther lose their seven-year-old
daughter Annabelle in a free car
accident
about 12 years later in 1955 The Mullins
decide they've spent enough time without
a child so they open their doors to a
group of orphaned girls and the nun
tasked with their care a Woman by the
name of Sister Charlotte when one of the
orphans a girl named Janice stumbles
upon a porcelain doll in a locked
bedroom she unwittingly releases a demon
that wreaks havoc on the house and its
inhabitants it soon revealed that
following their daughter's death The
Mullins had been tricked into letting a
demon take possession of one of Samuel's
dolls and it's now decided to try and
find a human host by the end of the
ordeal the demon has succeeded in
possessing Janus who escapes and now
going by the name Annabelle winds up
being adopted by a nice family in Santa
Monica where she grows up runs away
joins a cult and then returns to murder
her adoptive parents in 1967. talk about
a downbeat ending
so
which one of you gets this
as it turns out the nice family that
adopted Annabelle lives next door to
John and Mia form the main protagonists
of 2014's Annabelle John has given his
wife Mia an antique porcelain doll as a
gift for their unborn child but after
Janus Annabelle and her boyfriend kill
her parents they move on to the form
residence where Annabelle takes a sudden
and deadly liking to Mia's antique
during the struggle she takes her own
life and transfers the demon back into
its original home
Terror sets in as the demon doll decides
that Mia would make a nice Soul
Sacrifice the couple is helped by a
local Bookseller named Evelyn and their
Parish priest father Perez the latter of
whom tries to take the doll to Ed and
Lorraine Warren but is attacked before
he has the chance willing to sacrifice
her own soul to save her newborn
daughter Mia tries to jump out of her
window with the doll luckily Jon and
Evelyn arrive in time to stop her and
Evelyn takes the doll and Mia's Place
there has to be another way there is
I can make it right
in the end an unsuspecting woman buys
the doll from a toy shop as a gift for
her daughter a nurse here's where we
finally get our first proper
introduction to Ed and Lorraine Warren
in 1968. that nurse whose mother had
given her a very hideous doll as a
present is now at the mercy of the demon
Spirit trapped inside the toy and she
needs the Warren's help in exercising
the thing so the warrants take the doll
off the nurse's hands and move on to
their next case
in 1971 in Wakefield the Warrens are
teaching a class on demonology at
Massachusetts Western University one of
the attendees at the Warrens demonology
lecture is Carolyn Perrin a wife and
mother whose family has recently moved
into a Rhode Island Farmhouse and
unfortunately they're now being
tormented by a malevolent clap Happy
Spirit
give me the third clap
but it's not all fun and games when it
comes to this health spawn after some
digging the warrants discovered the
house was built on land that once
belonged to a witch named Bathsheba who
sacrificed her weak old child to the
devil before hanging herself and then
spent the following Century possessing
and killing future residents Ed and
Lorraine suggest the family move into a
motel temporarily while they tried to
get the Catholic Church to agree to an
exorcism but Bathsheba has already set
her sights on Carolyn and the now
possessed mother brings her kids back to
the house to kill them the warrants show
up in time for Ed to perform a rogue
exorcism on his own and the curse of
Bathsheba is lifted leaving the parents
with a livable Farmhouse and the Warrens
free to move on to a new case
a year after all that in 1972 when Ed
and Lorraine Warren are needed on an
overnight investigation they hire a
teenager named Mary Ellen to babysit
their daughter Judy this turns out to be
a terrible decision not only did the
Warrens at this point in time have an
entire room devoted to possessed objects
in their home but Mary Ellen has a
friend named Daniela who really wants to
speak to her dead father Daniela drops
by the house Uninvited and does what any
girl in her position would do she finds
a way into the Warren's artifact room
disturbs Annabelle and unleashes every
ghost and Demon the Warrens have trapped
in their basement
The Doll ad
it's a beacon for other spirits
understanding that the three girls set
about trying to get the doll back in her
Glass Prison hoping that will stop The
Haunting the girls spend the night
essentially playing hide and seek with a
bunch of possessed objects before
annabella's return to her case once and
for all
valik makes its return in 2016's The
Conjuring 2 the film that sees Ed and
Lorraine Warren finally defeat The
Marquis of snakes maybe beginning in
1976 the couple is investigating the
infamous Amityville murders and Lorraine
has a vision where one of the murdered
defeo children leads her to the basement
and she comes face to face with Valic
and a vision of her husband's death
the rain continues to see visions of the
demon none even as the pair traveled to
Enfield England where the Hodgson family
has been experiencing Paranormal
Activity when it appears as though the
entire haunting is a hoax put on by the
family to gain Fame the Warrens pack up
their things to leave but Lorraine soon
realizes that valik has been behind the
entire thing and they returned to the
house in a last-ditch effort to save the
eldest daughter Janet who at this point
is possessed and trying to jump out a
window Ed grabs her but almost falls to
his death in the process leaving
Lorraine to go head to head with valik
herself she succeeds in banishing the
demon by using its name and pulls Ed to
safety
action
close call
a few years later in 1981 the Warrens
document The Exorcism of a young boy
named David glatzel unfortunately the
evil spirit in David overpowers it and
makes a deal with Arnie Johnson the
young man dating David's older sister
Debbie Arnie offers himself up in
David's place and the demon accepts
though Ed sees this happen he loses
Consciousness for over a month giving
the demon possessed Arnie just enough
time to murder his landlord eventually
Ed and Lorraine learned that David was
possessed only after first being cursed
by an object built by Isla the occultist
this leads them to Father Kastner a
retired priest who has previously dealt
with a cult called the Disciples of the
ram it turns out that he's also the
secret father of Isla who he
accidentally exposed to occult practices
to save Arnie the Warrens destroy the
altar that Isla built expelling the
demon before it can do any more damage
unfortunately for Isla the demon returns
to its former Master killing the
occultist and dragging her soul to hell
Ed and Lorraine's story isn't done just
yet a fourth Conjuring film titled The
Conjuring last rites is currently in
development with Patrick Wilson and Vera
Farmiga returning his everyone's
favorite paranormal investigators
produced Once More by James Wan and
Peter Safran last writes looks like it
could potentially be Ed and Lorraine's
final Conjuring Universe Adventure no
matter how it plays out it'll be great
to see them tackle the forces of evil
yet again additionally a Conjuring
Universe TV series is also in the works
at Max which may be another spooky
Avenue for the Warren's most hideous
adversaries to rear their ugly heads
given how early in development the
series is we don't have many details in
fact you could say we have none
foreign